ciao a tutti intorno alle solite stories
oggi video epico
vi faccio vedere la mia connessione di
tribal tantissimi sly quei tantissimi di
più vi farò vedere quanto tutti gli
giorni farò sentire anche i suoni asr in
più potete fare un gioco mentre
ricordate e cioè indovinare in che video
ho fatto lo sly vediamo chi è che alla
memoria migliore di tutti per voi
indovinate in che video foto lo slime
che vi farò vedere è in che challenge va
bene alcuni ha fatto l'italia con gli
opa ti vediamo chi indovina più 3 euro
di più su questo video aggiunge i 20.000
l'aics lo so sono tanti ma ne vale la
pena perché farò un video super epico e
cioè forse avete già capito mi schierò
tutti questi slime quindi se questo
video raggiunto i 20 mila la ex di
schino tutti i miei live si lasciano il
nose live smooth di ex zigtech non ho
idea di che colore è uscito a chi sta
non ho idea di come si radica e
consistenza di quanto peserà quindi se
lo volete scoprire se volete che gli
istituti non saper ballare
su questo vi di più in questo video
pezzo che vi rilasserete un bel po
perché vi farò vedere appunto tantissimi
traini farò sentire i suoni a smr e
quindi mettetevi come se volete mettere
le cuffie poi miei commenti mi potete
mettere il times abidin stampo con jack
che vi è piaciuto più di tutti così
scegliamo un vincitore tenevi comode
rilassatevi bagatin e pop corn e
iniziamo subito allora iniziamo da uno
piccolissimo magari facciamo dal più
piccolo al più grande non lo so vediamo
comunque iniziamo da questo super
piccolino questo sono davvero da più di
un anno vediamo come diventato in
pratica questo era un mini fra pista mi
sembra un po oddio al palline dentro
allora devo dire che se apple non lo so
una consistenza è un po strano ma solo
veramente da tanto tanto tantissimo tra
i move non venissimo zeligtube slime
dorato e giallo con i glitter rosa
bissoni anche questo purtroppo un po
appiccicoso perché può purtroppo si
sciolgono tutti ci sono 40 gradi tipo in
questa stanza mi piace un sacco che il
colore e il glitter
se volete potete dare il voto da 1 a 10
a tutti questi slime che voto date
questo zeligtube prossimo slime chievo
qua uno slide super ditte roso con anche
delle palline dentro
[Applauso]
eccolo qua forse sera della neve finta
in questo slime perché è una consistenza
molto particolare un consiglio se lo
stress si sciolgono passaggio mangiare
poco poco di attivatore e ri mescolarli
per un bel po
siamo slime è un altro celli cube questa
volta è perché questo mi sembra che
avevo fatto in una challenge avverte con
la colla bianca il che è strano perché i
genitori che si fanno con la palla
trasparente e allegri per dentro vediamo
un po a sentire è un po metallizzato mi
piacciono un sacco i suoni che potevi
date dalle ore 10 e si mostra in meno
slime super glitter hoso dentro e
trasparente ea dei bottoni sedia un po
eccolo qua guardate che glitter hoso
anche questo purtroppo sarà un po
sciolto per il caldo però non riattivato
un po che porta di dati da una di sia
davvero tantissimi tweet live poi
abbiamo semplicemente un click slime
purtroppo con la colla trasparente che
uso non è completato trasparente ma è un
po giallino quindi non escono mosso tra
spareggi vedete è un pò giallo cosa ce
l'ho da meno tempo infatti non si è
sciolto come gli altri
ecco qua un bellissimo clear il cliente
uno spam
molto semplice però rimane bellissimo
che voto di date prossimo estremo questo
è uno stress unicorni in questo caso è
uno slime comprato
[Applauso]
molto bello perché viola trasparente con
i glitter e a questo unicorno dentro
presti mousseline abbiamo qua penso sia
un bel the cake slime rosa con le
palline
[Applauso]
ho molti sono i granchi quante palline
che ho
[Applauso]
non capisco libertà
che appunto dati a queste slime prossimo
slam ma abbiamo qua penso che sia uno
snow slime vediamo mondo è una sorta di
snow slime glitterato
e rimasto molto morbido
massimo slime questo è uno slang offerte
quindi immagino che sarà uno dello slide
dell'eccellenza che abbiamo fatto con
vitale di yahoo diventato tempo però non
è male il colore una sorta di color
menta se un po indurito questi
contenitori non vanno molto bene massimo
slime questo serve un po particolare
alle stelline sotto e sopra di abate ti
amo te tipo parlato quasi una pallina
del colore
ben venga una sorta di blu si parla
travo
per morbido con le stelline rayman
offline villa che coralmente l'abbiamo
fatto in una challenge diritto
[Applauso]
prossimo slava m uno strano rosa penso
che sia un grossissimo vediamo due super
morbida si è un grosso sembra una gomma
da masticare e un po gb limita bagno mi
piace tantissimo
creative di dare sempre i botti nei
commenti prossimo slime è un host line
molto particolare involtino che sia
stata una challenge questo perché verde
e poi è un mix mi sembra o per carità
che io mischia per gli inflight quando
non ho più contenitori disponibili a
riccardo slam voi ve lo ricordate
ver date quasi un pon pon orme allora a
un po di tutto questo slime dentro
bambine spugnette
[Applauso]
l'aima molto particolare questo slime è
tipo trasparente dentro si sono un
milione di decorazioni quindi immagino
che sia stata una challenge è un colore
un po particolare vedi a un po ep
letterato
guardate quante decorazioni a
ingredienti
guardate a un sacco di cose dentro
pazzini sfrutta glitter e super soffice
abbiamo non so se sia un mega flop è
bello grande celeste vediamo a questo
penso che fosse quello fatto con la clay
mischiato con il claim a chi è un po
duro si è proprio quello è un po rigido
eccolo qua place lime
prossimo abbiamo una sorta di boboli con
un po di palline vedi un po anche vari
l'inter prossimo abbia uno slam super
strano perché sono tipo due strati di
sla in questo pre viola questo pre
trasparente sotto un sacco di conchiglie
ha un sacco di roma dentro un bellissimo
tempo aspettavo di trovare queste
palline sopra a suoni
[Applauso]
che bel colore
tante quanti colori a qualche amico di
cose dentro anche le conchiglie
[Applauso]
prossimo salari ma non capisco se perde
john cos'è questa cosa forse ho capito
che estrae mera questo questo era quello
fatto con i palloncini scoppiando i
palloncini al buio
cosa è diventata una sorta di bar de
rossi
[Applauso]
grazie
wow
[Applauso]
numerose questo che strano e bill colors
8 e tipo me roma è super glitterato e
sopra un portalino chiaro viviamo
simo slime vediamo chi si ricorda che
slime è questo super super titoli
[Applauso]
oddio se stesso si stanno staccando dei
pezzi gialli karateka delfino un aperto
la